ich wohne jetzt hier seit ich ein Kind
bin habe ich diesen einen Traum von
meinem eigenen kleinen Bauernhof vor
fünf Jahren habe ich angefangen nach
diesem Hof zu suchen wenn wir den Hof
kriegen dann wird das hier meine neue
ziegenweide und es folgten endlos viele
Besichtigungen absagen und wieder runden
die ich verloren habe wir haben gestern
Abend den Hof abgesagt
weil es einfach letztendlich zu teuer
ist und dann habe ich diesen Resthof von
1850 gefunden und ersteigert diese hoch
gehört jetzt auf mich ich glaube das ist
jetzt endlich soweit wir werden an
diesem Ort leben
warum ich einen Bauernhof will deshalb
ich liebe Selbstversorgung und es ist
meine allergrößte Leidenschaft überhaupt
unser eigenes Obst und Gemüse anzubauen
morgens die Eier aus dem Hühnerstall zu
holen unseren eigenen Käse herzustellen
im Sommer die Ernte haltbar zu machen
und unsere Vorratskammer bis unter die
Decke zu füllen
genau das mache ich seit über 10 Jahren
und nein dafür braucht man nicht
unbedingt einen Hof bis vor einer Woche
habe ich in einer Wohnung mitten in der
Stadt gewohnt und keinen Quadratmeter
eigenes Land besessen und für meine
selbstversorgeprojekte einfach immer die
Augen offen gehalten nach Grundstücken
die so ein bisschen verwildert aussehen
dann habe ich die Besitzer gefragt ob
ich die Grundstücke gegen Pflege nutzen
darf und so immer genug Platz gefunden
um meine selbstversorger-projekte
umsetzen zu können aber immer das ganze
Werkzeug durch die halbe Stadt
transportieren zu müssen und nie auch
nur einen Obstbaum Pflanzen zu können
war auf Dauer einfach unbefriedigend ich
war so dringend einen eigenen Bauernhof
mit festen Zeugen wo keine Ziege in
diesem blöden Elektronen zeigen bleibt
bitte
einen Hof gefunden ich habe gerade den
Kaufvertrag unterschrieben heute in 7
Tagen bekommen wir die Hausschlüssel ich
kann gar nicht sagen wer aufgeregt da
ist mein schwieriger Sohn oder ich
jedenfalls habe ich für uns beide einen
hofcountdown gezeichnet auf dem wir
jeden Tag ein Hühnchen anmalen können
bis es dann endlich soweit ist und wir
unsere Schlüssel bekommen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine Woche vor dem Umzug hatte ich die
glorreiche Idee erstmal meine komplette
Wohnung auszumelden dafür schmeiße ich
immer alles was ich besitze auf einen
Haufen und gehe dann jedes einzelne Teil
durch und gucke ob ich das wirklich
wirklich behalten möchte und ja das ist
mein Weihnachtsbaum der hier noch steht
Anfang Juli frag mich Leute frag mich
aber wer mit dem Weihnachtsbaum noch
etwas sehr schönes vor
[Musik]
heute ist der Tag an dem wir die
hofschlüsse bekommen fünf Jahre ist es
ja dass ich den ersten Hof angeschaut
habe und ich hätte nie im Leben gedacht
das ist so lange dauert bis wir endlich
an dem Punkt sind und trotzdem ist es
jetzt so absurd dass heute der Tag sein
soll an dem dieser Traum Ware wird ich
freue mich so
wir ziehen erstmal nur ganz provisorisch
um mit einer Matratze und Zähne
Umzugskisten und unserem Weihnachtsbaum
und sobald wir den Fußboden fertig
abgeschliffen haben und alle Wände
gestrichen sind machen wir dann in ein
paar Wochen den großen Umzug auf den Hof
kann ich den Baum rauswerfen
da kam so drei ältere Damen vorbei und
die haben sich sehr gefreut wie gut
erhalten der jetzt ist
[Musik]
raus
ich bin einfach so
fast 17 Jahre betreibe ich jetzt
Selbstversorgung auf den Grundstücken
von anderen Leuten musste immer zum
Beispiel zum Melken zu meinen Siegen
richtig weit wegfahren jetzt können wir
einfach alles was wir machen wollen
direkt hier am Haus machen und mit
diesem
einen Schritt dass wir jetzt hier sind
kommt es mir auf einmal völlig absurd
vor dass ich das jemals anders
hingekriegt habe aber es ging so lange
aber so schön dass das jetzt einfach
nicht mehr sein muss es kommt bald noch
eine komplette Hof und eine Gartentour
auf meinem Kanal aber hier seht ihr
schon mal wo später der Gemüsegarten
hinkommt und als nächstes sind wir in
die scheinen gegangen und haben alles
noch mal ganz alleine für uns erkundigt
[Musik]
ihr habt ja mitbekommen dass ich mich
seit Ewigkeiten auf den Hof freue aber
auch wie schwer es mir gefallen ist von
meinem alten zu Hause und dem alten
Garten Abschied zu nehmen und
tatsächlich bin ich jetzt wo ich den
neuen Garten habe und anfange richtig
große Pläne zu schmieden so gut wie gar
nicht mehr im alten Garten wir sind
wirklich so gut im neuen zu Hause
angekommen es ist einfach so schön hier
es fühlt sich so richtig an hier zu
leben und es fühlt sich irgendwie so an
als wenn wir schon immer da gewesen das
ist so seltsam
[Musik]
wir kommen überhaupt nicht mehr
hinterher mit der beerenernte mit den
ganzen Kirchen wir waren schon so ein
bisschen zu spät eigentlich für die
Kirschen also die meisten sind einfach
schon faul wenn wir eine Woche früher
eingezogen oder zwei wer ist perfekt
gewesen aber wir konnten nicht mehr so
viele retten leider aber dafür gehen wir
in Bären unter das ist der Wahnsinn ich
mache jetzt gerade noch ähm fruchtleder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ursprünglich war der Plan dass wir uns
in den ersten Wochen voll und ganz auf
die Renovierung konzentrieren damit wir
möglichst bald einziehen können aber ihr
kennt mich ich kann es nicht lassen das
Haus kann warten im Garten es ist
einfach viel schöner
[Musik]
[Applaus]